they probably thought that this was
behind them and now WikiLeaks out with
all of these emails released to the
public you know and there's a lot of
people already commenting about this
tweeting about some of this information
as well journalists as well as the
Senators in the u.s. there a chris dodd
he actually commented on the saying that
this wikileaks is violating the privacy
of sony employees of those involved and
said that the information stolen was
part of this illegal cyber attack so
essentially WikiLeaks assisting in this
act here but again more than 30,000
files 170,000 emails now leaked on to
WikiLeaks if you go and search this is
what's going to look like on online
there you can basically search through
all the emails through all the documents
and it really shows some more
information that we really didn't get to
see too much of last year particularly
talks between Sony Entertainment CEO
Michael Lynton about relationships
between Japan and Korea this was during
the time of the before the interview
release here which is the film that's
said to trigger this entire cyber attack
here the US blaming North Korea for it
but in a statement Julie Assange the
WikiLeaks editor-in-chief talked a
little bit about why he did this he says
basically this is should be public
domain this is the center of
geopolitical conflict and that this
shows the inner workings of an
influential multinational corporation
here and it's newsworthy for the Met
parts and so Sony coming out saying you
know what we're condemning this recent
release here you're assisting these
cyber attackers here we're gonna do
whatever it takes to fight for the
security of our more than 6,000
employees it's embarrassing it's
potentially more damaging but in terms
of the financial impact Sony stock
doubled in the six months since the
initial hack attack does this latest
leak even matter yeah you know some
analysts say probably not because
they've already kind of turned a new
leaf and all this you really try to put
this behind them they've already changed
their systems they've got the results
they're barely fazed by this attack you
talk about the earnings from there the
picture is more than double their
estimates from that preliminary estimate
that they had earlier so the third
quarter profit wise was a beat it beat
almost an all fronts there so the worst
the damage they say may have already
happened already so we'll see what
happens if there is any reaction today
and Sonia shares are but they are down
but one and a half percent right now